[Music]
detective mulligan with all due respect
i don't want anything to do with cletus
cassidy well that's too bad because he
only wants to see you in my opinion you
had your chance with cassidy and you
blew it
right um so
what does he want maybe he wants to
spill the beans about where the missing
bodies are buried
so you're gonna have to do the right
thing for a change
anything you
want to unburden yourself with before
and
this
happens
yes
i have wishes
to bestow upon you
i
want to wish you
this heartbreak uh-oh
too late i wish for you to see out your
days alone as you always have been watch
it pal
where are you going with this you
are a cancer to everyone who ever loved
you eddie
deceived your trusting fiance
and no wonder daddy could never look at
you again after you killed his wife your
mother
just by being born
have tasted blood before and that is not
it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
[Music]
i've been thinking about you because you
and i
are the same where you going with this
i'd like you to meet
carnage
exclusively movie theaters october 1st
welcome back everyone this is my new
venom let there be carnage trailer video
they dropped a whole bunch of new scenes
with a bunch of spider-man easter eggs
carnage venom even toxin easter eggs for
those of you that want them to do the
toxin symbiote so we'll break it all
down and tom hardy was also clarifying
how they're working with marvel on their
big spider-man tom hall in crossover
movies too if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i'll be doing full breakdown
post-credit scene easter egg videos for
the movie when it comes out next week
we've also got a lot of spider-man no
way home stuff that's going to be
happening really soon too so you won't
have to wait too long to actually see
these characters and these universes
start slowly crossing over they also
just announced that they're going to be
doing a special marvel disney plus day
in star wars disney plus day later this
year with a bunch of trailer footage so
i'll talk about that at the end of the
video too right now there's so much big
stuff coming up before the end of the
year it's kind of like trailer city but
the first new scene here is detective
patrick mulligan who is toxin in the
comics the offspring of carnage talking
to eddie brock trying to get him to go
visit cletus cassidy in prison hoping
that they can get some more information
about all the bodies that he hid that
they never found and it's all just part
of cletus cassidy's obsession with eddie
brock just trying to mess with him but
as you can see there's a lot of tension
between patrick mulligan and eddie brock
i think they're just laying the seeds
for potential talks and arc in the
future of the venom movies the way that
tom hardy explained them planning that
stuff out is that he said they have
plans for another couple of venom
sequels but they think of those as being
separate from the big tom hall and
spider-man mcu crossover movies so for
instance they've already confirmed that
they're crossing him over with tom hall
and spider-man i posted a clip of them
talking about that in my last big venom
let there be carnage video but when they
do that movie it won't be like venom 3
or spider-man 4 or anything like that
it'll just be like a separate movie off
to the side they call those side quals
because it's not quite a sequel but it's
kind of a sequel using the map of the
marvel multiverse here from loki this is
so useful i'm so glad that they did this
on loki because now we can use it to
talk about universes crossing over
between different franchises if the
initial giant line across the bottom of
the frame represents the mcu main
timeline one of these giant branches
coming off of it represents the venom
movies in a different universe picture
venom 3 venom 4 however many more venom
movies they do is just continuing along
this giant branch timeline towards the
top of the frame while the mcu timeline
just kind of continues on its own
direction then you have events like
spiderman no way home where doctor
strange and spiderman do everything they
can to just completely mess up the
multiverse where events cause these
different universes the different
timelines to sort of overlap briefly and
you can have characters crossing over
which is how they're explaining all the
tobey maguire spiderman characters in
the andrew garfield spiderman characters
winding up in spiderman no way home
marvel and sony just chose to make that
a mainstream main mcu timeline movie
whereas the way that tom hardy explains
it when they do spider-man venom
crossover that'll be more like a side
adventure it won't be like a mainstream
spider-man movie it won't be spider-man
4. so tom hardy just explained that
that's the way they pitch when they're
talking to marvel and he did make it
sound like they pitched them ideas all
the time about spider-man crossovers
like how about this idea like how about
a maximum carnage crossover and kevin
feige and marvel just sort of evaluate
that based on what their own plans are
for the future of tom holland inside the
other marvel movies like avengers 5 and
the other non-spider-man movies that
they want to use them in so for instance
if venom 3 winds up being venom versus
toxin the offspring of the carnage
symbiote they would just continue on
with that storyline in their own
universe picking up where they left off
in the events of the previous venom
movie but the way the new marvel and
sony sharing deal works with them
allowing these characters to actually
cross over now is that they do allow the
sony people in the venom movies to
reference spider-man things like they
can have spider-man easter eggs like we
have jay jonah jameson and we have the
daily bugle inside venom let there be
carnage the only time they get really
weird and tricky with how that works is
when you actually have physical tom
holland as spider-man in a spider-man
costume crossing over with venom on
screen any other time the sony people
are allowed to reference spider-man
related easter eggs and even more so
once tom holland actually crosses over
with venom the reason why you didn't see
a lot of those spider-man easter eggs in
the first venom movie is because they
were playing it safe and they made that
movie before they signed the brand new
spider-man sharing deal but then in this
other trailer footage you have a much
longer version of him going to see
cletus cassidy and cletus cassidy
getting the carnage symbiote which as
they explain here is a bit of a change
from the comic book version it's still
sort of venom's offspring but it's like
the venom symbiote mixing with cletus
cassidy's blood in the combination of
their dna just completely changing it
into a wholly different symbiote
speaking of which he also says to eddie
in the trailer footage i would like to
introduce you to carnage and then
obviously the carnage symbiote comes out
usually it's the symbiotes that wind up
naming themselves like the klyntar their
race they have their own names their own
identities so unless i'm misremembering
i think they were actually accurate to
that in the first venom movie where the
symbiote was already named venom and
told eddie that its name was venom
leggetti himself didn't give it the name
venom the way they played in this
trailer makes it sound like cletus
cassidy gives his symbiote the name
carnage but the reason why that might
happen is because it's a brand new
symbiote that's just being born when it
enters his body basically as opposed to
the other symbiotes from the first venom
movie which were alive for a long time
like matured by themselves and then came
to planet earth like they already fully
developed as symbiotes before they
started bonding with people on earth
speaking of maximum carnage in the
shriek character they also just released
a brand new scene of shriek inside her
cell in ravencroft institute the
interesting thing about her character is
that even though she's a spider-man
character like she debuted in the
spider-man comics she debuted as a
mutant and i know everybody just
wondering what's going on with really
mainstream mutants in marvel phase four
what about the x-men characters how will
they explain her powers in this will
sony be allowed to use the term mutants
in the venom movies the way they explain
her backstory in the spider-man comics
is that when she was younger she was
shot in the head and then put into
cloaks special cloak from cloak and
dagger which acts as sort of a gateway
to the dark dimension and exposure to
the dark dimension energy awakened her
latent mutant abilities and as you can
see from the trailer she just has a
sonic screen that's basically her power
but unless marvel gave sony permission
to use the term mutant inside the
venomverse movies the spider-man related
movies that they're doing on their own
they wouldn't be able to have any of the
other characters refer to her as a
mutant verbally during the movie they'd
have to just call her something else or
be mysterious about it be very vague
about where her powers came from it just
hopes that they also work out a sharing
deal like they did for spider-man but
for mutant and x-men characters too so
that sony can start crossing over some
of the other x-men characters when it's
relevant for their films which does seem
likely to happen eventually there's a
billion lesser mutant characters from
the x-men marvel comics that will
probably never see the light of day in a
mainstream mcu movie it's usually just
the a-list characters like spider-man
himself wolverine the mainstream x-men
characters that studios are more careful
about but if marvel and sony can share a
character like tom hall and spider-man
probably one of the biggest comic book
characters of all time then anything is
possible a really good example of a
different type of crossover between
marvel and sony's spider-man movies is
doing like a morbius and blade crossover
which seems like a pretty easy slam dunk
if they wind up doing morbius sequels
don't worry even though it's been a
while since they've talked about the
morbius movie they're still planning on
releasing it in january there'll be all
kinds of spider-man easter eggs during
that too just because of michael
keaton's vulture character as well as
that giant picture of spider-man the
tobey maguire spider-man costume as for
all those disney plus trailers and
special announcements that they just
made so marvel says november 12th
they're gonna have a special disney plus
day where they drop a couple trailers
and some footage for upcoming series
that they haven't talked about in a
while like maybe a moon night trailer a
she-hulk trailer maybe some footage from
miss marvel and announce release dates
for all that stuff then reveal more
upcoming series that they haven't talked
about previously because they have a
billion different series that are in
development then as part of that star
wars is also doing the exact same thing
the star wars trailers we're probably
going to get will be a full book of boba
fett trailer that's like mandalorian
season 2.5 we might get the obi-wan
teaser trailer for the obi-wan series
which also features hayden christensen
as darth vader and anakin skywalker and
then more teaser announcements about
upcoming star wars series like the
mandalorian season 3 the ahsoka series
the dark side acolytes series and maybe
some other stuff that they're working on
that they haven't announced yet so don't
worry i will do videos for all the big
stuff that they release as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all that stuff when i post it
my full marvel what if episode 7 video
will post next on wednesday just like
normal it's going to be the party thor
episode everyone click here for my brand
new eternals trailer video for kit
harington's black knight character and
click here to learn what's going on with
the sinister six inside the spiderman no
way home trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you